trent
is in indiana hi trent welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hey thanks dave i really appreciate you
taking my call
first off i just want to say i bought
your book entre leadership great book
thank you and i've binge watched
probably over hundreds of your videos so
i really like those too
my question for you is i just i'm about
to graduate this friday
as a pharmacist and i'm in um 180 000
just in student loan debt i have no
other debts i'm planning on i'm living
at home
planning on paying as much of my income
towards that as i can
my question is what would be a good side
hustle to do that's flexible that's not
uber lyft
because from what i from what i've
looked up right right until until i'm
licensed until i can do more hours with
that
yes oh how long before you're licensed
it'll take about a few months just
because of cover 19
and like scheduling state exams it'll
take advantage i'm studying for that now
yeah do you have a job lined up as a
pharmacist when you complete that
i do so it's i'll start off working
there unlicensed
as half pay and then once i'm licensed
it'll be full pay as a 90 grand a year
it's 90 000 a year yeah that's the full
pay
right with the opportunity to work up to
work work more overtime hours if they're
available which they usually are
yeah i would take all i can get of that
and get your income up as high as you
can get it once you pass
so what are you going to do as a side
hustle what do you think is a good
income
producer i i don't know that's
i don't know that's going to ask about
because
how it's set up right now is i'll be
floating around to like different stores
until
i get like a staff position and then the
hours would be more set so it's not like
i can say
well i have weekends open so i can work
you know x amount of hours here
yeah can you can you uh well so you need
something you can plug in and plug out
um i mean it's up to you
i really think you probably have a you
know forty five thousand dollars a year
is half pay will they give you a bunch
of hours during this training period
uh i'm not sure yet we have orientation
coming up here next
month so i'll also ask those details
yeah that might be your best side hustle
is just
more hours of that i mean you'll make
more doing that than you would anything
else
yeah i'm just thinking long term once i
can like build up enough stamina to work
you know the 40 hours a week to do more
than that
well long-term i don't know i guess i'll
have to do some some
some more research and thinking about it
well i mean long term you're going to be
a pharmacist
long term you're going to be working all
those hours in overtime and if they
won't give you overtime you pick up some
at the er
and some other stuff at some other
places as far as
what to do to do those jobs you have to
do like a couple years of residency
before you can kind of pick up some side
hours but yeah but yeah for like some
there's something
i'm seeing kids do this all the time
coming out of pharmacy school
not all of those jobs require residency
so i mean you need to step in and listen
you've studied really hard and you're
really smart to get this degree
this is your best place to make money
and the interim
before you get licensed and after you
get licensed and you don't need that
much stamina to work over 40 hours it
doesn't take that much you can do it